like okay so take australia for example
right um
in australia they made um prostitution
legal
right they made prostitutes and legal in
australia
and in australia they made they
but what but what they done
but what it done with prostitution is
that it brought it into
houses it wasn't on the streets right so
you have what you would call them [ __ ]
houses or whatever right but like
there's like 24-hour
like uh-huh that prostitution houses
right and you know what happened when
they made prostitution legal in
australia
the divorce rate in australia went down
by eight percent
really yeah
it was kind of like a show went down
when that men were happier go into
whorehouses it seemed like right and
being able to do that
then when they weren't when prostitution
was illegal so it's kind of like a peep
show house
and how would i'm just curious how would
feminism fight for like the equality
when it comes to sleeping with people
because you can't change society like
you can't
you can't look at everyone in this room
and say look at everyone the same like
they're not going to
um okay so there are biological reasons
the way we feel the way we feel so in
general women date men taller than us
and the reason for that is because
historically like we used to have to
find a guy to protect us so if he was
taller than us he could protect you
better
so men it's the same thing with body
count
historically they couldn't have a girl
that slept with a lot of people because
they had to ensure paternity they had to
make sure that the kid that the great
birthday was there and they weren't
raising someone else's kid
so they can't help that they feel that
way about girls sleeping around it's
just part of their hard-wiring just like
we can't help that we feel that way
about wanting tall men
and like girls will say like short men
ain't [ __ ] short like i wouldn't ever
and look at i'm sorry i'm one of them
sorry shortcake
i won't say there ain't [ __ ] but like i
just like i'm more attracted to guys
taller than me
and like men don't complain about that
like double standards in that way
i mean i just don't think like feminism
is a so so it's your sociological thing
but you're talking about a biological
thing so you can't really compare the
two
so i don't understand so you're saying
it's a social media honestly me neither
i'm really confused
i'm just saying like
the the reason why men find women that
sleep around um
i guess negative
is because
like he's like pearl said we need to we
need to secure the fact that our seed
our legacy so what you're basically
saying is that men can't help being like
that because it's a biological thing
yeah it's a biological thing okay well
that's just changed it then like biology
can be changed within a lot of time with
time with time yeah
actually i heard women but women
than men no how come you come like a
biological thing that men have more
because women are attracted to men that
have more sexual partners but women get
hornier actually a woman wants actually
sex way more than a man yeah but okay
yeah no okay how come hang on
logical
that way that could that could be true
it is true but that
no i'd say that could be true but when a
man is a virgin he doesn't know what
he's doing in the bedroom is that
attractive
it's cute
[Music]
she is the exception i said
i said
i said is it attractive is it is it
attractive it's not a bad thing everyone
so a man so okay so a man like i said
earlier on the conversation a man that
knows what he's doing in the bedroom
yeah that knows what he's doing is more
attractive to a woman a man that knows
what he's doing in the bedroom is
experienced okay in sex he's experienced
right he knows what he's doing a man
a man doesn't mind teaching
a woman what to do in the bedroom so if
she's less experienced than him right he
doesn't mind teaching her and kind of
like what people call turning someone
out right a man doesn't really mind
turning a woman out in a bedroom right
but a woman doesn't want to be the one
to tell a man how to please her where
the clitoris is what to do with her body
she's like oh my god this guy doesn't
know what the hell he's doing
right so you want a man who's sexually
experienced
but you have to tell every man where the
[ __ ] is
well i don't know what man you've been
talking to
everything sarah said i know where i
started every time you don't speak for
every single one how old are you you're
20.
how does a man feel about that then
since like if a woman you're saying like
if a woman
doesn't
like a man who's not experienced what if
the roles were reversed so how would men
think about a woman experienced so okay
so i'm i'm okay this is very interesting
inside the mind of a man so a man who
finds a woman that's got a lot of
experience understands that she's being
quote-unquote for the streets
right
and he will have sex with her but he
won't make her his wife
thoughts
he won't he would definitely have sex
with her and he'll enjoy that sex but
he's not thinking this is going to be my
wife she's been with like 100 men or
whatever he's thinking
whatever whatever number you put in your
head i'm just saying he's a legendary
girl
that's not true no there are some there
are some women here some men think like
that but i think that's real really
wrong because probably
are you telling me that a man as a man
who is very experienced in sex it's
because probably she's been in a long
relationship and she knows a lot because
she's been you know doing for a long
time period not just with one person and
then on another person you know what i
mean it's just like uh i feel like
that's very judgmental
but you can feel the way you want to
feel but i'm just saying that's man
you're very experienced you've been with
a lot of hoes too you are a hoe as well
no no but women but women are okay women
want a man with sexual experience
they want a man with sexual experience
so you as a man what do you want from a
woman not experienced so you can feel
the men on we understand this teaching
her
yeah
yeah yeah exactly
you get it exactly
so i'm saying you guys want a girl that
has no much experience so you guys feel
like ah macho man you know ah i'm the
teacher i teach you are you feeling part
of like ego right you guys have a big
ego yep you're probably there i'm so
glad you're
okay good good okay good for you so
anyway i would say you see i lost a lot
of strain of food because you're talking
about down there that's why no because
you imagine very much
your mind went elsewhere
focus
you confirmed there you
so in order a man to be uh able to be
experienced you need to try
different girls right
right right but those girls have been
experienced by you by other men too
right but how come you think you're
gonna find a woman then that is not an
experience
no akka said um and i said this on
the show before there is a there's a
fine line and i think you know i think
some men may be a little bit delusional
here but there's a fine line and we want
a woman we know that women of this this
generation aren't virgins we know that
we know you've had a few sexual partners
maybe a few relationships et cetera et
cetera but we don't want to know that
you're a quote-unquote it's probably
going to upset people we don't want to
let you we don't want to know that
you're a whole
we don't want to know that you're a
whole okay what we want is okay cool we
know we're not the first guy that you've
been with we know that but we don't want
an actual hole that's been with like 100
men
that's not what we want but if you but
if you act that way we're like okay cool
this is cool sex great sex but i ain't
gonna wipe this girl because she's been
like i could be walking down the street
and the next guy walks past me and he's
like
um
that's your girl
that's your girl yeah oh we me and my
friend's done
you don't want not okay uh okay but
that's again judgmental because for
example i've been in a relationship for
seven years and then i met this guy for
a year and a half and he wanted a and
he's arab and he wanted to marry me you
know and i'm more experienced than him
no but i'm saying you were in a
relationship that's different you were
in a relationship with one man for seven
years that's different we're talking
about a woman who's been with like
but how do you know she's been like that
you don't want to know but that is why
that is why people ask about people's
body count
because they want to know uh-huh they
don't know how many people you've been
with
i mean what the same for
not
i can't speak for every female though so
for me like if i heard his body count
was like 50 or 100 i'm gonna be like oh
my god
have you been tested
right yeah yeah yeah no no that's not
for me that's not attractive to me yeah
i don't want i don't want to hear like
like like i said they don't want to hear
about a cat i don't want to hear that
i don't want to hear that you've slept
with the 50 to 100 people
but you do want him to be sexy
experience though
i would say personally yeah
yeah but i just don't want you like
so i guess to an extent so drake asks to
take you on a date yeah drake asks to
take you on a date
you're not going
i heard about him he's fine but you know
okay a date's fine a date's fine but if
you get
he's trying to date you
or a guy like that it might not be drake
but your celebrity crush okay okay
that's clearly been with a million
okay so if he told me
this is me personally if he told me he
was like with 50 or 100 men it's
probably more of those guys yeah
probably more i don't i couldn't do it
you couldn't i couldn't do it i don't
care how famous they are